please welcome academy award winner
kevin costner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening
you know
you know about a
half a mile from here
i saw my first full-length
adult movie
and i know what you're thinking but i
was uh
i was seven years old and i was away
from my parents and
wanted to have some fun
it was a cowboy movie
called how the west was one
and what i witnessed that afternoon in
the cinerama dome
was perfect
the curtain
when we still had them
opened to a film almost
four hours long
it had an intermission
where the score continued
subtly signaling at one point that
the second half was about to start
i don't know where everyone went but i
wasn't going to move an inch
i decided that i would not
give up my magic seat
i was determined that i would not miss a
minute
and as i sat in that dark that afternoon
sixty years ago
all i really knew was that i was in
careful hands
little did i know that three directors
would be responsible for that epic
moment in my life
they fired my imagination
and they captured my heart
and that's what can happen when you
direct a movie you can change a mind
you can change the trajectory of a life
of a career
you can capture a heart
but you can't do it alone
and directors
the tonight's directors all know
the possibilities they know what's at
stake
it's why they give their precious time
it's why they choose to fight
through the long days
and the longer nights
and the endless questions
and the inevitable second guessing
that comes from those who would do it
differently
if given half a chance
these five directors
have all managed to stay the course
they have all held the line
and masterfully given us the gift
of a single vision
and for that we honor them
here are the nominees for achievement
and directing
kenneth branagh belfast
ryuska hamaguchi drive my car
[Music]
paul thomas anderson licorice pizza
jane campion the power of the dog
[Applause]
steven spielberg west side story
[Music]
[Applause]
and the oscar goes to
jane campion
this is the second oscar and fifth
nomination for jane campion who is the
first woman to be nominated for
directing twice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you kevin that was very dramatic
oops
just want to say um
big love to my fellow nominees i love
you all you're also extraordinarily
talented
and it could have been any of you
new zealand and australia
i love directing because it's a deep
dive into story
yet the task of manifesting a world can
be overwhelming the sweet thing is i'm
not alone
on the power of the dog i worked with
actors
i moved to call my friends
they met the challenge of this story
with the depth of their gifts benedict
cumberbatch kirsten dunst cody smith
mcphee
jesse plemmons
and my whole crew who are true hearts
i thank my brilliant producers tania
segacion who was always by my side
emile sherman ian canning and roger
frappier also kate richter
netflix your whole awesome team
embraced this film from the very
beginning thank you so very much
and my home people my family you know
who you are especially alice my daughter
he's here
and tony my beautiful partner
you gave me so much love and
encouragement and made it fun
but it would be impossible without the
man i never met thomas savage he wrote
about cruelty
wanting the opposite kindness
thank you academy it's a it's a lifetime
honour thank you thank you
you